can i play an old this is this is an old
this is pretty old
from 2008 but it doesn't have that many
views 161 000 so it's not that many tell
me if you've heard this before
um this is a dude who
left the voicemail dimitri the stud uh
so dimitri martin
oh no i remember the this is old school
this is
this is this is like o a old school yes
yeah this is dimitri the stud let's
check out dimitri instead
yeah hi they're all goods dimitri sorry
i had to leave such a rushed message
with you uh
when we uh met the other day i just want
to quickly give you
my phone number and i had to get the
heck out of the area
in any event i figured i'd better leave
you he talks like in family guy when
they have those foreigners
like we'll have a pint of beer i was
going to bone my girlfriend
but i could not bone her the other day i
just want to quickly give you
uh my phone number and i had to get the
heck out of the area
in any way i figure i'd better leave you
more mcdonald's he's busy
yeah i was i was gonna give him my
number but i had to get the heck out of
there
of message um i approached you
i am single i have no trouble meeting
women
i mean women approach me six seven times
a day boy this
this guy is off to a great starter women
love when you're alpha
they love when you immediately start
talking about awesome
but what i like you're extremely elegant
i couldn't take my eyes off of you and
your friends were very jealous
even if they say they weren't they were
envious of the fact that
uh i approached you and i was very taken
by you
women are very rare and i'm very
particular about what i like
he's greek i'm giving you an opportunity
here i don't know if you pick up the
messages on the weekend but i'm
i'm working on a movie script so i'm
pretty much around all weekend
doing that working on a movie script
this guy is the best
he's working mike what lady wouldn't
want somebody that's working on a movie
script
this is like uncomfortable
he's way too confident right he's way
too confident and
autistic and like but like yeah like
most people with this lack of social
skills are self-aware
so they're just like um i was wondering
maybe
like sometime you wanted to go see uh
the new avengers movie with me but this
guy's like uh first of all let's get it
straight i am a handsome man
i have no problem meeting women you're
very elegant
like you're just like where is this
confidence coming in this is elliot
rogers dad
seriously like this is the kind of guy
that makes like way too much eye contact
yeah
i left you my number 416-918
four this looks like a landline
and if it is you may not get the message
till monday but when you do call me
so this girl gave him her business card
so he called her office and left the
voicemail
that's from what i've picked up from
laura okay yeah yeah yeah now i
that's oh it's so wonderful so he's one
of those like you know he probably was
talking
business or something with her she goes
yeah here's my card you know that's what
we call their office
and then we'll get together for coffee
and chat and to let the romance begin
you look very taken aback by my approach
and i hope that isn't timidness i hope
it was just a little bit of
shock at being approached so um uh
directly
uh because i don't really date timid
women oh my god with this guy he doesn't
date timid women do you date timid women
i don't think you date a lot of women so
you don't get him i'm a very direct very
passionate very assertive man
this sounds like a dating site video it
does dating videos
i want a woman who's very independent
and strong
so anyway we'll talk about that but i
just wanted to formally introduce myself
now i have i leave the ball in your
court you call me
as soon as you uh have the courage to
okay olga
cut the courage the balls on this
courage too my god i really wish i know
this is like
ancient internet lore but i really know
what this guy
looked like or who he was yeah i don't
know talk to you soon bye
so then she doesn't call him and then
this is the following
she's too timid is that what it is yeah
well then why is he calling her back he
doesn't date him
you're about to see hey there old guy
it's dimitri calling again
the guy from the street i left you a
message several days ago
you said you were interested now here's
the way i work
i don't like leaving second messages but
i like you you're very eloquent this is
a serial killer am i
he doesn't likely no he's a gentleman
with what time wasted i do not like what
making more than one
message okay he i said you were elegant
let me touch your skin it's like dude
relax
interested now here's the way i work i
don't like leaving second messages but i
like you you're very elegant woman
you're very attractive you've said that
yes
you know i don't play that game i know
your friends tell you not to return
calls you're playing games like you see
on stupid tv shows so here's how it's
going to work
it is now 4 30 on wednesday
now i'll assume i'll assume that you've
already left work
because you know some people leave early
and i'll grant you that
i do not receive a phone call back from
you
by three o'clock thursday afternoon
i'm no longer interested and you can
erase my number
i don't play games like that he doesn't
i'm completely single
i'm he's he's completely single
this guy's he's completely single he's a
catch
but like this did you hear he was
writing a movie script earlier
if you told me that
this guy had like i don't know they
found like eight female skeletons in
this guy's house i'd be like
that's it i would say that's it it'd be
like keep digging
very intelligent i'm great in bed i make
great
i love this guy right in bed he's great
in bed
jesus i'm very intelligent i'm great in
bed i make great money believe it or not
i'm a complete catch i've only been
single
four months i had a long distance
relationship you know when a year it's
very tough to maintain
it like that and it didn't work out
there's nothing wrong with me
matter of fact i'm one of the few men in
the city that has nothing wrong with him
what is he pleading like he's one of the
few men in the city
this is insanity i it's been by the way
i mean
we probably both heard this what 10 12
years ago it's been a while this is an
old old video
but i haven't listened to it in so long
it's crazy like back then i just
remember laughing at it and goofing on
it but now you're like with different
perspective you listen and you're like
what is wrong with this man yeah he
should you think he killed somebody for
real he had to have right
he has the demeanor of a killer yeah of
a killer
so i'm giving you that three o'clock
deadline if i don't hear from you
you lose my number i'm erasing yours
right now
so you won't be hearing back from me so
that's it
three o'clock tomorrow or you can just
completely forget it
now i understand if you've got other
issues like maybe you're not
playing games maybe you've had i don't
know maybe you were abused in childhood
maybe your mother has cancer you're
going to chemo
maybe you're just the person who's
extremely frightened or has
some has an anxiety disorder maybe
you're on
some medication for that i don't know
there could be another issue
that i'm not aware of but nobody says
call me hands a person a business card
and then doesn't return
calls it's extreme they do when they
left the voicemail you left you [ __ ]
crazy i didn't realize but this guy is
legit
like i i didn't know but he's got a
whole encyclopedia dramatica article oh
really
he's a real demetri the lover a passive
aggressive
he's canadian you should actually look
that up passive aggressive personality
disorder
and you let me know if if you've got
issues
psychological issues if you're on any
sort of medication
for anxiety or depression i'm not
interested
okay but if you're psychologically
normal
and you haven't called me because
there's been some horrible thing that's
happened in your life which prevented
you that's fine
but otherwise don't call me okay bye
he's an angry boy he's a legit serial
killer
and then right and then right after uh
right after he hangs up he turns back up
hip to be square
and he just starts killing somebody it's
it's
there's a very weird sinister type
element to him right yeah be very very
creepy
like it's not just being an alpha like
just in his ways
and he's got his little rituals like
that's kind of [ __ ] scary man